grave is a scrap I'm all-in but I can't
control guns oh there there on the left
oh where oh nice spot mate everyone's
fighting I've got a hammer
Billy when did you get a kill I'm just
trying to stay humble alright guys
welcome to celebrity squad battles this
session is all about getting better at
battlefield 5 ahead of our livestream in
January so we're gonna be going through
loads of tips and tricks just everything
we can do to get to the best that we can
at the game so first things first
Billy you're gonna be playing support
Anthony you've got an awesome shot so
you're gonna be playing as recon from
there Courtney you'll be running in with
me with assault so I'm feeling confident
let's get into it
guys let's get into it all right I feel
like we can get a win right so what you
do if you've not got a medic in your
team who's giving you health packs you
need to go resupply at bases so every
base which you can also build a
fortification art they've been destroyed
simply go down here oh my that's ammo in
it yeah it's a note so back because it's
because someone's destroyed the health
one if I bit I build the health one up
here you'll then be able to grab med
packs from here oh my gosh right I've
got I've got a question right from what
you've seen so far all right would you
want a Billy in a real battle or is the
would it be a liability Bill's
grave is a scrap of all in but can't
control guns you know on statistics on
this pretty weak but for morale he's
great definitely really know you can
always read into stats you know we're
all together for the first time so I let
this all group up right let's go up to
this top Ridgeline on the left yeah I
get the high ground now we've gone nice
other there on the Left okay yeah oh
where oh nice spot
well I've gotten babe there you go which
is nice that was a great fun all right
where do you two let's all head over to
a well the big thing that I want to be
doing making sure you all together right
Billy right you need to be heading
towards aid to support your team so you
right now go into the wrong side maps
have your head right right you just get
it you're just hiding in a corner you
know you're not being the support that
you know to be right now right so so a
question forever Oh believe it's got a
kill Oh headshot so question favor
what's your favorite way so I'd take
down the opponent you'd like kind of
getting a sniper kill from a distance
you prefer like picking up a killing
like a tank or rocket launcher what's
your favorite thing I like hiding in
corners and one of them to run past me
only dealing headshots bra so it's been
good and we just finished captured
captured a so I think now it's a good
point
to wrap it up guys this is actually a
big moment right in celebrities got
battles yeah that is the first match
anyone has won in the training section
of celebrity squad battles but that is
actually the first one I think the fact
is that us as well best would know first
things first
right I've done this I want to ask who
do you think is the MVP Billy who do you
reckon I've Courtney Anthony was the MVP
[Laughter]
right what is a who do you think most
kills I'm gonna say Courtney will see in
January Courtney how about you who do
you think MVP definitely I'm from now
okay
overall I think we did a pretty awesome
job so remember to make sure to tune in
to the live stream we'll be back playing
again to you guys
so yeah make sure you follow the page
[Music]
you